um
like you said uh ceelo the original nine
on the project
um you know we've we've noticed how
uh hard it is to get andre versus fans
over over the last x amount of years you
know we
sometimes will get one a year and just
be super excited it might
pop up on a jeezy album or a remix or
something um
it's only right that he's on the new
goody mob album but how
how how uh how the andre verse come to
be and like was it was it difficult
i know it's not difficult because y'all
are family but like you know that's an
important verse to have on a goody mob
album with organized noise behind the
production
man we won't even speak about the
difficulties or whatnot you mean like
you know we'll just only
speak about the end result you mean like
you know and uh
the end result is the camaraderie the
connection
you know um the respect the dignity the
love
and i mean like you know the blood i
mean like you know that we
it's a it's a family thing i mean like
and you know we
we embrace each other's indifferences
man that's that's part of what made
us very special man like you know
everybody is unique in their own right
it resembles the right let me like to
be that to me like and and voice that
they may like and so like
jordan's one of those highly integrable
people he's an
artist artist you know what i mean right
and i also like to consider myself as
such but like
since we speaking of him i mean like you
know
we've grown we've grown to just embrace
the fact that man like
something that he's truly not into you
know i mean like
you know he ain't into it and i've seen
dog like
just just like you know just for fun i
just tell you man we've seen
what turned out multi millions of
dollars everybody know that
ain't never said like we could all smile
and laugh at that because it's like yo
like you know and that that way the ball
was set but so anything that he decides
that's that he don't necessarily want to
do him got no passion for it
you know me like nobody could even
really argue with that because we're
going to see him turn down
all kinds of [ __ ] i was so excited you
know
it was it's crazy because as a fan i was
afraid that i was going to die without
ever seeing outcasts perform in my life
and then a few years ago they did that
festival run
and i got to see them in tampa and i was
like all right that's off the bucket
list you know